hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Minecraft today
today I'm gonna find out where the hell
those guys are and obliterated from
these pieces and then I'm gonna go to
the nether to be fun there's a reason
why I made sixteen buckets there's a
reason and that reason is because I was
destined to go get an entire lakes worth
of lava and bring it up to the surface
and that's exactly what I'm going to do
so with that in mind I'm going to get
the necessary supplies to go get lava
namely bucket and I'm gonna go down and
I'm gonna get it and that's all that I
have to say about that
alright let's go get ourselves some Lobo
oh did I really really block up the
entirety of this is there more I hear
more oh okay there's some somes better
than none Oh interesting
Oh interesting where are you coming from
oh maybe we got more diamonds Oh buddy
boy I didn't know that there was another
lake over here oh my goodness
Oh what's going on there wait right
there that looks like he was blocked up
this is this just like connecting dude I
mean I imagine that I've been to all
these various places before no this is
just
oh no I've been here okay so okay lava
thank you
look look look
I have lava buckets surprise me buckets
don't melt but hey is it possible to get
unlimited lava it's possible anyway it
doesn't matter
I've got lava and now that I've got lava
what I'm gonna do with this lava is I'm
going to build an ember portal I guess
stop talking like that
I'm gonna build a nether portal a nether
portal okay so the question is where am
I gonna put this gosh darn lava where do
I put lava fall batter ten times better
than waterfall but it won't go in cuz
would be a problem
lava farm farm up some lava no no like
this under that lava in my lava farm
labo well I got a regular well and then
I got a lava well how about lava fall
into this river you know what I mean oh
cool yeah no this is gonna be rad oh
this is gonna be rad oh this is gonna be
rad okay okay yes yes and now my girl
Lava Falls opens we is les I thought it
would like Gousha a little more but I
guess it's not very goo she oh yeah
that's Gucci alright oh that's nice oh
that's nice I'm gonna get one more there
we go baby there we go baby
well alright well we got a fire
fill it up a little more rounded out I
don't know why I don't even know if this
is like an efficient probably not fine
to guess anyway I got a lava waterfall
that's pretty cool okay so I can't grab
from up there so what I did was pretty
much pointless a waterfall was a bad
call on
yeah you're gonna flow backwards buddy
no you're not gonna flow backwards okay
stitch Skoosh Skoosh Skoosh okay nice
okay so that's kinda better right
I don't know man look i-i'll put let me
I don't even know how this I know this
makes obsidian well I I guess I not a
hundred percent certain about the
mechanics I used to I had a lava river
just want a river of lava be purged one
no wait no I need to use this to do that
oh my god that took forever Oh ice
bucket challenge hey cool new recipes
what is that it's at the enchanting
table it's at the enchanting table is at
the table of enchantment
it might be the devil oven jamming
sploosh okay I did it I might have to
get rid of [ __ ] waterfall I might
actually have to get rid of my lava
waterfall which would be a great tragedy
however the other great tragedy is the
fact that you've given me more
complicated crap that I don't know how
to do enchanting table why would anyone
why would anyone do that why would
anyone do it to themselves and how dare
you I should have just brought watered
down why didn't I just bring why did I
bring lava up why didn't I bring water
down my god I'm an idiot don't do the
water down thing I'll just go bring
water down oh okay fine
alright you water I mean lava get ready
to get wet not a sexual thing oh it's
dark Oh
dork it's dark out oh wait what if
there's a lava underneath it oh I would
have lost it oh you almost got me but
not this time baby
I'm too smart for you hey wait I can
just make another photo here and then
it's like I could jump in the lava who
knows
alright well that helps that mm-hmm
mm-hmm
well you guys are still here you're
persistent and I don't like it well that
didn't help anybody it didn't actually
mmm-hmm okay I'm gonna get you oh my god
oh this is why I need the Enchantix
table so I can just make a better
pickaxe risky game risky game there mr.
Ripley a risky game I need one dude
ten ten pieces oh my god I need ten
pieces Oh lick seeing at the time lapse
[Music]
okay 12 okay 12 I got 12 so I can also
paint 14 okay I got I got him I got the
ones I did it
I'm magnificent oh go away okay I did it
I got 14 10 for the portal for for the
table now back up I go and to the lovely
light of day now I'm gonna make this
nether portal I don't know why any human
would ever want to go to the nether I
don't know why what's the point
it's not a light of day it's the dark of
night there's some redonkulous nests as
summer dunkey long key how do I may I
need Flint I've got Flint I've got went
I need one of you and you give me one of
you and yeah I've got that and you've
got you and then how do I make a table
okay for obsidian two diamonds I don't
have two diamonds hopper what you did a
hopper for what's a hopper what are you
hopping who's hopping what Golden Apple
why would he make a Golden Apple what's
a Golden Apple for I don't know any of
these lantern that's cool that's cool
that's that's pretty cool how do you
make iron nuggets I'm alright that makes
sense that's pretty cool
that's really cool wait no that's
actually cool new recipes what do you
mean new recipes what do you mean two
recipes I don't know we're talking about
oh whatever
okay Lantern no no what
but it's a lantern but it's oh oh I want
it here can you put him on the ground
perfect there you go now I've got
lanterns but that is cool that is pretty
cool you got to admit you literally came
out I left the door up in there
kill me they're gonna come get me I'm
fine so now I have all of the things
that I need to make the nether portal oh
wait no this is gonna be sick
okay I cannot mess up if I remember
correctly I think I think Oh cameras
this is temporary okay gonna take that
away okay okay this is pretty sick
though right for sick you know what I
mean you see what I'm getting at
pretty sick you gotta go into the river
Allah oh yeah pretty sick right my hands
okay it's another time to go in baby I
am so prepared for this I'm prepared for
it let's go this is what we set out to
do why not do it right what's the worst
that could happen
all right Oh whoo I'm hot I'm high up
really high up oh wow we zowie you Wow
whee okay well I'm here now
oh how do I get down you seem to have
presented me with the issue of getting
down you made it very difficult for me
to get down what is this garbage where
did you put me am I gonna have to build
a bridge across this I will I will I
guess oh I don't like this oh I don't
like this
what is
in me please do that's the most horrible
thing I've ever heard in my life I hate
what I'm doing what I'm doing is awful
what I'm doing is the worst this is
terrible idea this is a horrible idea
oh this is the worst idea I've ever had
oh if I fall oh I'm going to die so hard
what if that thing blows up my bridge
don't think about it put it out of mine
get out of the universe my butter has
never been clenched lick scene makes
that family-friendly oh okay it's really
quiet
you are gonna blow up my bridge you were
gonna do it I know you were I know you
are I hate this place I hate everything
about it I hate all of it kind of the
worst not gonna lie it's really the
worst it's actually maybe the worst can
I drop down oh okay I'm just gonna build
that up like that like it was destiny
baby not the game but the thing that
makes it so that I can approval of
everything I do
des des the thing that means I'm not
every capability any mistake destiny oh
I don't like this jump it didn't have to
be a jump I kind of built it across yeah
what is this what are you what are you
what is it hmm what did I get
what is it nether quartz what is that
never gotten that in my life never ever
had that hard bud
okay what's nether quartz for never
heard of that I've never heard of it oh
there's music you don't like another all
right you want to fight you wanna dance
you wanna dance with me pants okay
nevermind reflect you know I shouldn't
try to that can you all fight and kill
each other that'd be greatly appreciated
hi bud what are you doing you coming for
me try try me try me yeah you would
never try me you couldn't try me
Yipes alright I'm gonna kill you Wow
get back here stop being an [ __ ] who
you're gonna send me to the beyond it's
me oh you're not as hard to kill as I
thought you might be oh I am
all-powerful I'm not gonna kill you
because I have a funny feeling it's
gonna end in my own demise let bygones
be bygones hey you're pretty pretty
anybody ever tell you that I bet not
well because you're so hideously ugly
but I think you're pretty yeah stop stop
they're looking for their brother mushy
may I have that mushy may I have mushy
can you stop standing on the mushy so I
can have it I was just normal mushy okay
okay so here's the thing I don't know
what I need from in here and I don't
know why I'm here let's go take these
for the mush ease oh it's almost death
[Music]
that just goes down oh you know I would
loved if the portal would have put me
like on the ground if there if there
even is ground here oh my god I'm almost
making an oopsie I don't know what is
all here and I don't know why I have
some quartz is that enough no no no no
you stay away from me we're doing a lot
of pigs a lot of pigs alright you know I
had my fun I'm a go now I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go because I see no reason to be
here seems like there's a whole lot of
nothing so I'm gonna go I believe I'm
leaving goodbye goodbye oh why do I want
it why didn't I just build this path I'm
gonna make this jump I'm gonna make it
I'm gonna make it I'm gonna make it
fully fine safejump totally safe totally
fine
I bet where did you come from well i'ma
kill you
you can't stop me I'm gonna kill you you
can't stop me wham wam wank
when and where like why Louise you're
dead well all the way she's not dead I'm
going home I hate the nether my
conclusion about that experiences that I
hated that was awful why did I go there
what in the hell was any of them would
milady like a fine chicken hello lady
what are you gonna be like that oh
you're gonna get the business now get
the business you get the business how oh
oh oh oh chicken
save me oh oh oh oh oh oh oh I'm dying
Oh worst thing horror why ma'am I
offered you a fine chicken this is how
you repay me you evil evil uh hey kill
you kill you
Wham that's what you get come on come on
you want to go you want to go you want
to go you want to go you didn't miss the
I you didn't she don't miss even in the
heat of battle she don't miss huh yeah
yeah okay you suck so bad I hate you so
much I hate you so much you really suck
I gotta farm I didn't eat I'm hungry
can't kill you I'm hungry so shut up
why go away evil demon Enderman and you
get some go
you were really painful you want that
guy's really hurtful oh you you get
bumped on my go no oh that's right yeah
you better yeah I got shield baby now
you're dead all my delicious experience
is gone now I'm gonna kill this witch
where is the witch you you're nothing
I'm gonna kill you anyway this man can't
run now hoho Oh dad how's it feel
how's it feel get away from my crops I'm
going to bed
that's what you sound like
game alright can I sleep now then I urge
away the demons who could even survive
in a world like this ok gosh well you
know that taught me a couple lessons
first and foremost of which is don't go
to another second of is witches are
really tough thirdly I I don't know what
to do with the nether stuff so what I'm
gonna do I'm going to do what I know how
to do I'm gonna dig a hole in the ground
I'm gonna make plant my sugarcane cuz I
know I need paper and maybe sugar
[Music]
hi how are you doing hey good can you go
away and never come back that'd be
really appreciated
[Music]
my goodness people are being awfully
sassy to me today how Michelle is gonna
die hungry I just need more dirt to fill
in the hole that they creeper blasted
into my farm good stuff and it's broken
and I'm digging with my bare hands but
you know I appreciate it you know maybe
I should dig with my diamond pickaxe
that'd probably be just as fun can't you
tell my my face how much I love it I
love it let me just finish this stupid
thing that I know I've done filling gosh
darn hole in two I'm in my hoe oh let me
go make a new hole me me a new shovel oh
my god I was almost done okay that's all
I wanted to do oddly enough that is
shockingly all I wanted to do and now
the cooter gravy shook up okay I can't I
thought I could turns out I cannot I had
this wrong
I thought that I could put him in the
corners a rosette I cannot I was fine
it's like a lily pond very pretty very
pretty that's exactly what I wanted
that's exactly what I wanted all right
I'm done this episode has gotten away
from me
but that's okay because I'm getting
better at minecraft if you don't fail
how can you succeed right great good
glad we're all in agreement about that I
need more diamonds to make an Enchantix
table but
tomorrow problem I can make one loaf of
bread today we got one bread and hey at
the delicious loaf if ever there was one
so thank you everybody so much for
watching more minecraft soon
check out drunk minecraft in your
minecraft down in the description and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]